[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTINE KAESER-CHEN:
Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to Google.
I'm super excited to be here
and super excited to welcome you
here in Google.
And I'm here to
tell you a bit more
about how we're building for
more immersive virtual reality.
So I was born and raised in
China in a city called Chengdu.
And my mom used to work for
the state railway company.
So what that means
is when I was little
and I could travel
for almost free,
I traveled with her
on many train trips
all across the country.
So I guess that's
when the travel
bug started to grow in me.
And I went to Hong
Kong for university.
I attended this beautiful school
called the Hong Kong University
of Science and Technology.
You can see a picture
here on the screen.
It's the second one.
So the campus sits
right next to the ocean.
It has its own pier, had its
own beach, it was gorgeous.
The experience in
Hong Kong not only
gave me the good foundation
of mathematics and computer
science, it also
opened the door for me
which has led to
the wider world.
So during my undergrad, I
spent a whole year, literally
a whole year studying,
working, and traveling
in the United States,
in the United Kingdom,
and in continental Europe.
During that time I went
to Northwestern University
near Chicago, and that's
where I met my husband.
After undergrad I
moved to Switzerland.
I went to ETH Zurich and
spent three years there
studying computer science, and
I loved every minute of it.
And at the end of 2012, I
moved here to the Bay Area
and has been working at Google
for almost four years now.
So I love traveling, I love
cooking, I love the outdoors,
and I also love New York.
I just returned from a
six and a half week trip
with my husband
across South America.
There have been so many places
I've been that there's just
beautiful nature,
amazing wildlife,
and many extraordinary cultures.
So along our trip, there
have been many times
that I will stop at a point
and tell my husband that this
is gorgeous here.
I wish our family
could be here, or I
wish our friends could
see this, or I just
wish that people
could experience
what I'm experiencing
at that moment,
even though they were
not physically there.
So that is what has led
me to virtual reality.
The power of virtual
reality lies in
that everyone could travel as
far as their imagination takes
them.
The constraints
in the real world
will no longer be
the limiting factor
of what you can experience
in virtual reality,
and I find that super exciting.
I think there's so
much more we can
do to not just organize
the world's information,
but to gather the
world's experiences
and make them universally
accessible and useful.
So let me tell you a bit
more about Google's story
in virtual reality.
Our journey started with
Google Cardboard in 2014.
And that was a 20% project.
What that means was a bunch of
us, like around 15, 20 people--
I was lucky to be part of it--
we spent 20% of our
time, a few months,
and put together
Google Cardboard.
It was announced and
launched on Google I/O 2014.
And after the initial
success, the group of us
actually banded together and
started the VR team at Google.
It has been more than
two years since then.
And since then, we have
launched Google Cardboard V2,
which was 2015.
And last year, we announced
the much improved Daydream view
and controller system.
So a lot of what we do
in the VR team at Google
is focusing on how do we
make virtual reality more
accessible to more people?
How do we make it
easier for people
to share this experience?
And one central question
leading that way
is actually, what makes good VR?
Is it more resolution
on the screen?
Is it a wider field of view?
Is it maybe haptics feedback?
Or is it like spatial audio that
will go along with the visuals?
And the answer is all of them.
All of them are very important.
So here is actually
three examples
of the good elements that
would make for immersive VR.
The first one is probably
the most known one.
That is called motion
to photon latency.
What that means is a time
lag between the moment
I turn my head to the moment
the screen updates to reflect
the new view port.
There have been numerous
studies to suggest
that if the time lag is too
long, this may cause nausea
and this may cause
motion sickness.
And we don't want that to
happen to any of our users.
And the second one is
also very interesting.
The second one means
the representation
of your body in
virtual reality should
match the pulse of your
body in the real reality.
So it is a very
interesting experiment.
You can close your
eyes and you can
try to touch your nose
with one of your fingers,
and you can still do it.
What that means
is our brain knows
approximately where
our body parts is,
even if our eyes are shut.
And what that implies
in virtual reality
is we need to
render, for example,
your hands in the approximately
correct location of where
your hands really are
in the real reality.
And then the last
thing is interaction.
That is probably the most
interesting of all here.
That means the ability of
users to actually make changes
to the virtual
reality environment,
and let the environment
respond to you.
That will elevate
the user's feeling
to be an observer in the
virtual reality environment,
to a participant
in the environment.
So I had the
experience that once I
was watching a movie
in virtual reality,
and actually it was
kind of a game setting.
And there was a robot dog
that was coming to me in VR.
And of course, it's
not a real dog.
And I looked at
the dog and the dog
looked back at me into my eyes.
And I was like, wow,
I was really there.
So that is what makes
VR experience magical.
So the Google
Daydream team has been
working towards building
all these elements to make
VR great, to make VR a
more immersive environment.
I'd like to tell you
a bit more about what
my team is working on.
So after observing many
people spending time
in virtual reality, sometimes
even spending their first ever
time in virtual
reality, one question
popped up more often
than the others.
The question is,
where are my hands?
We've seen many people,
the first ever time
they put on the headset,
they raise up their hands.
They will be like, oh,
I can't see my hands.
Where are my hands?
Where am I?
And this is such an
important question
because hands are our
primary interaction
tools in the real reality.
And not being able
to see them or use
them is disorienting,
sometimes even confusing.
And on the contrary,
if we somehow
start visualize the hands in
VR, the power is just magical.
So there was once I was
trying a VR experience.
There was a virtual fireplace,
and I kind of put out my hand
to be right above
the fire, and I
start to feel warmth
in my hands even
though there is no real
fireplace below my hand.
And many people
reported the same thing.
So the group of us set out
to answer this question.
How do we bring hands to VR?
This is a very hard
question, because
from a image-based
approach, we can
collect a number of images
and videos and hand poses
and movement.
But if you look at
your hands, there's
a lot of self occlusion,
there's a lot of articulation.
And if you compare your hands
with your neighbor's hands,
you may notice that
the size and the shape
will vary dramatically.
And that means traditional
computer vision approaches
normally don't work
very well here.
But fortunately, the
recent advancement
in deep neural networks
provided us with a new way.
The power of neural
networks is that it
can learn the
important features,
and then the depth
of the neural network
means that it can model
very complex functions.
And therefore, the neural
networks, once trained,
they have a good tendency
to be generalized
very well across a wide
range of test data.
So we have built and trained a
neural network with TensorFlow.
And you can see a sneak peek of
what it can do on the animated
images on the right.
So you can see that not
only can you see your hands,
we can track key points.
Therefore we can
draw on the screen
and can interact
with UI elements.
And I'm super excited
that the TensorFlow
team is here today as well.
And they will give a
workshop this afternoon.
And if you're interested
in machine learning
or artificial
intelligence, they both
have great documentation online,
and I suggest you check it out.
So what would you do with that?
What would you do with
having your hands in VR?
I personally believe that
we can enable a number
of creative applications.
For example, you can
paint, you can sculpt,
you can make potteries, but it
can also give you super powers.
Perhaps all of us
can be Yoda in VR
with our own
virtual superpowers.
So the question is,
what would you do?
What would you like to
see in virtual reality?
I'm super proud to be
here to actually tell you
the hard work done
by these people.
What I just told you is
not my accomplishment,
but the accomplishment
of the whole team.
I'm super honored to be working
alongside with these very
talented people.
And with that, I'd like to
thank you all for being here.
And I hope you enjoy
the rest of the event.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]